welcome back to this channel in this
video we'll be discussing a very
important subject that I know several
Pak Farmers have on their mind in
turning Pig farmers and that's the
question around uh what kind of size of
pig should I start my farm with so uh
one of the first question is should you
start with uh a pregnant Pig like the
one you see in the video right
now or should you start with the winners
like what you can see right on the
screen
also should you start with the Growers
like what you can see right on your
screen also and last but not the least
should you start with a matured but not
yet pregnant Pig so in this video we'll
be talking about these four different
sizes of pigs and which one is best for
you to start your farm
with quickly before I continue if you
new to this Channel please quickly click
the Subscribe button on this channel we
bringing to you lots of great videos
great content on profitable P farming
all you need to know the a to set of P
farming will'll be dropping it right
here on this channel so please hit the
subscription button and hit the Bell
notification so that you can be notified
each time we upload a new video all
right let's delve right into it so what
size of pig should I start with as a new
farmer as a an aspiring Peak farmer what
kind of size should I start my farm with
now the pregnant pigs are are the most
expensive size of pigs amongst all that
I showed you not withstanding what
breeds you are dealing with the pregnant
pigs are always the most expensive and
you can agree with me why they will be
the most expensive obviously because
every um seller understands that you
getting them means you getting not just
the mother alone but you're getting
additional number of piglets alongside
so and it could vary from 5 to 15 so
therefore every farmer selling to you a
pregnant Pig will obviously sell at
premium because everybody understands
that you are getting a jackpot by
getting a pregnant pigs a pregnant Pig
so why should I start or why should I
not start with a pregnant pigs that's
what we'll be answering in this
video all right let's do it mat quickly
uh
a pregnant Pig of a pregnant tn70 brid
will cost about
400,000
Nara okay 400,000 NRA
now the grower pigs will cost about
80,000 to 120,000 n and the the winners
May range from there about 50 to 100,000
depending on wherever you're getting
them from so we will use the cost of
50,000 or 60,000 for a winner 100,000
for a gr for the
grower and 400,000 for a pregnant Peak a
pregnant s now look at the mat getting
one pregnant Pig will get you there
about four to five grower pigs or about
six to eight winner picks now what do
you feel is best for you do you think it
will be good for you to have I
understand there's an argument you will
bring up in your mind but do you think
it would be good to get just one
pregnant Pig what
400,000 or four or five gr pigs what the
same amount or 6 to eight winner pigs
wor the same amount now many of you will
say okay it's not just one pregnant Pig
I know that's the argument going on in
your mind you still have about probably
like 10 or 15 or there about of piglets
in the home so why should I not get a
pregnant Pig well the point is when you
look at risk the risk of this whole
thing because as a good businessman you
need to know how to mitigate your your
risk risk is extremely important when
entering any business you need to
consider uh mitigating your risk
whenever you getting into any form of
business so if you're going to dump 400k
on one hanima with the risk of Poss
possibly losing its piglet because you
don't have 100% assurance that you're
going to get those piglets due to
several reasons uh it's possible you you
have issues while transporting them down
here because you need to understand that
one of the main key thing when bringing
a pregnant pig is for you to be very
sure you are going to get them safely
into your farm because the if the road
is Bumpy if the road is uh rough if you
have adverse weather condition you could
lose your piglet your s your pregnant s
could have bought or have miscarriage so
obviously those are some some happenings
that can happen while getting a pregnant
Pig now imagine you get a pregnant Pig
and that happens that's obviously a very
big loss because in the head you back to
square one more like you're getting back
to just having a normal pig without it
piglet but imagine you get a grow P or
rather imagine you get five gr PS now of
course the same risk still exist while
getting uh a grow Peak because it
doesn't mean you can be 100% assur that
you're going to raise the entire five
also to maturity but you know the risk
is mitigated because if anything happens
to one or two of them you still have
about three left or two left so you see
you have been able succeeded in
mitigating your risk because you need to
understand that no matter how much you
try there are certain situations that
could happen that are
unpredictable uh no matter how much you
do your due diligence so you want to
make sure you are on the saf side when
planning your business when getting into
your uh into Peak farming now imagine
you get five of these you raise them up
you learn so much while raising them up
you are able to grow as a farmer you're
able to understand the Integrity of peak
farming that
wiser that's better that's much more
advisable than getting a pregnant s
getting a pregnant s obviously if you're
a new Peak farmer you need to understand
that some sever question you should ask
yourself is do you have the experience
of managing a pregnant s to ensure it
deliver safely you know all it takes all
you need to do when it's delivering all
you all the maintenance all the
management practices that you have to do
the feeding all the nutrient it needs to
heat do you know all those things now
also when the pig deliver do you know
everything you need to do in terms of
managing the piglets to ensure that they
grow to maturity that you don't lose any
one of them just so you know I have a
friend of mine that lost his entire
piglet he had a pregnant sell the
pregnant sell delivered to gave bir to
ha piglet fine piglet fine fine piglet
but you know the piglet the the the the
mother
could not give the piglet milk and so
the pigs were okay the piglets they came
out fine they were okay but the piglet
could not suck so in no time at all just
in few days he lost everything he first
of all lost about maybe seven of them uh
maybe six in Con in in six went quite
early then maybe two survived to some
point then later on one went later on
the last one went in short he lost the
entire hit that's exactly the reason why
I would not advise you to get a pregnant
Pig now doesn't mean I did not say you
should not get a pregnant pig let me
state that very clearly I just mean of
course if you have the experience or if
you have an expact and you are very sure
of being able to handle it rightly
obviously you can go for a pregnant PE
but if this is not the case if you are
so new to Pi farming and you have no
idea of what it takes to ensure like
what drug are you supposed to give a
pregnant PE we'll be doing a video on
that very soon what are the care you're
supposed to give uh to a pregnant Pig
what when a pig deliver what's the drug
what's the medication you're supposed to
give it what's the medication you're
supposed to give to the piglet you see
if you don't give your piglet a certain
drug after 3 days about if you wait till
over 3 days you you if you're not
careful you will lose all the piglets
even though it gives the mother gives it
milk and let's imagine you even have a
mother that gives that doesn't have milk
what's the injection you're supposed to
give to to a pregnan a a sorry a a s I
just delivered that is not having enough
meal what are you supposed to do in that
situation so imagine you get a pregnant
pee and this that situation happens what
do you do that's exactly the reason why
I may not advise you to get a pregnant
PE but of course I said again if you are
very much experienced and you are sure
of what you're doing it looks like a
very good way to start because obviously
if you get two pregnant pigs or five
pregnant pigs you are getting about 50
piglets or thereabout from just a few
weeks and in just one delivery so
obviously that looks very catchy but
again that could be very risky if you
don't have the right experience you
could lose all your piglets and you
could lose your s that friend of mine
that I talked about almost lost the S I
knew all the things we had to do to
rescue that s to rescue the south from
North D he has already even lost hope
already and was considering uh calling
the buyer to to to get it but uh we did
some certain things on you know give it
some certain things some things I'll
will probably be talking about in
subsequent videos and the S survive
eventually so that's one of the reasons
why I would advise you to go for the
winners or for the grower PS this now
for instance if speaks you see on the
screen now if you get them on your farm
in no time at all in some few months
they would
be delivering they would take in and
give you your piglet and you would be
able to have the experience the
experience from feeding the experience
from management The Experience from how
bi security everything you need to do uh
to ensure a profitable pig farm you will
be able to grow into the experience
because I don't care how much you read
some books or how much you research the
internet there are certain things you
will experience only when you get into
big farming it's not it cannot be bought
anywhere what it's different from
watching a video than getting your hands
on this thing when you get into it you
will understand that it's so different
it's different from watching a video and
seeing how you know some of the time the
videos are just a summary of what goes
on on the farm you don't have an idea of
the challenges and certain things that
has to be done in order to ensure that
the farm is profitable until you get
your hands on this thing you may never
know so I will advise you to start with
uh little risk that means you mitigate
your risk rather than going for
something that could just quench your
entire money like your entire 400k could
just go or whatever amount you spend in
getting your pregnan out could just go
like that from just uh a mistake or an
ignorance you didn't know something
something happened and from there before
you count five your pigs are go your
your pregnant pig is go is gone but
imagine you had a a gr P or the winner
if you got five of them six of them or
or eight of them or even 10 of them if
anything happens to one you can learn
from that one and use it to uh you know
to correct yourself on the other on the
other one and then also if you for you
to understand the right drugs to use you
know the the how do you inject your paks
how do you care for them how do you feed
them all those things come by experience
so please from the the summary of this
video is whatever you want to do make
sure you're very sure of all these
informations around all these things so
you don't go into something that uh
makes you uh regret getting into Pak
farming so before you make the decision
on what size of pie to start with
consider all these things I've have said
the experience the cost and every other
thing that you may need to know and
ensure that you are you are positioned
right for whatever decision you make so
that would be all for this video once
again if you're new to this channel hit
the subscription button click on the
notification icon so that whenever we
drop a new video you are sure to get
them thank you very much bye-bye